greetings from podcastville
it's monday the 29th of march where the
[__]
did this month go it's just [__]
[__] pushed right through but no
worries from the heart of new jersey
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings
68 teams entered the tournament only the
best
are still [__] lurking the upsets
have been [__] wild
if you would have took the four dollars
forget about it you want to
loyola over illinois syracuse over west
virginia
oregon over iowa are you [__] kidding
me
listen draftking sportsbook is america's
top-rated sportsbook app
putting new customers in the center of
action not to mention
it's [__] fun but one dollar on any
tournament game
are you listening to me if your team
wins you win 100
it's that simple joey what are you
talking about i'm talking about one
dollar
turning into 100 it's 100 to one odds
pick any college basketball team that's
still in the hunt for your shot at
winning
100 and all it takes is a dollar bet
[__] that [__] bottle of water you
[__] i don't give you thirst to death
and you start seeing mirages
it's a lot better than what you're doing
one dollar your team wins
you go to the next [__] game there's
no better way to put your college
basketball knowledge to the test
to win the draft king sportsbook app
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app today right now
it's [__] monday use promo code joy
when you sign up
to turn one dollar into a hundred
dollars
if the college basketball team of your
choosing pulls off the [__] win
there's nba there's nhl there's [__]
poker
there's baccarat i mean listen they got
a [__] tremendous online casino
and draftking is safe secure and
reliable you withdraw your funds at your
[__] convenience so do me do me a
favor
seriously download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app today
use promo code joy when you sign up to
turn one dollar
into a hundred dollars if that college
basketball team or your children
pulls off to win who's better than you
nobody
that's code joey to turn one dollar into
a hundred hours
limited time only at draftkings sports
per cap i got to hit you with the fine
print
you got to be 21 older go chew bubble
gum somewhere else [__]
new jersey indiana pennsylvania
tennessee colorado
new customers only restrictions apply
you got to see draftkings.com
sportsbook for details now do you have a
gaming problem
i hope not it's not a [__] good
problem to have if you do
call 1-800 gambler if you're in indiana
call 1-809
with it but if you're straight and
you're looking to have a great [__]
time
this is the time to download the
draftking sports book app right now
use promo code joey and turn a dollar
into a hundred [__] dollars
draftkings promo code joey right now
right now as we speak
the joint is also brought to you by cbd
lion
listen i'm out of pt right now i got a
little muscle tear
every day i put on my little cbd line
extra strength unscented
cbd 1000 milligram cream
i'm on the gummy bears if you want the
capsules they got 30 plus capsules a
thousand milligrams apiece
kinesiology tape bath balls listen
tinctures gummies cbd lion is
top in their [__] field how do i know
because they brought me back from this
[__] surgery
i'm happy i'm stronger my joints feel
great
the kinesiology tape i've used it to
[__] death when i go to the gym or
the pt
it's fantastic stop [__] kidding
yourself go to cbdline.com right now
read read on cbn cbd cby
read out all the benefits and how it
could change how you're [__] feeling
trust me what i'm telling you this put
my [__] knee
tip top magoo go to cbdlion.com right
now and press in joey
or church and get 20 off your order
delivered right to your [__] house
i'm saving you money
on a [__] monday that's how we
do it all right go to cbdline.com right
now
and press in church of joey and get 20
off your order let's light this
[__] candle
i hope the thing is long enough there
you go
candles lit it's monday let's get this
[__] party started jack
welcome to uncle joey's joint
[Music]
[Applause]
greetings [__] it's monday thank
you very much for checking in
uncle joey's joining i had a great
[__] weekend i got to talk to you
about something then we'll get to it
friday afternoon i had to run around i
had to go to [__] uh
my wife had to drive me to some place
for my leg and uh i
had to go down to the dmv and see about
my license and do a bunch of [__]
things
i had a great weekend i got to see some
family
for dinner my my daughter ran around
with the [__] dogs you know the usual
[__] jersey living but
friday we got back i came downstairs i
was doing some patreon stuff and whatnot
and uh my wife came downstairs and she
goes listen i gotta go i gotta pick up
mercy the moms are getting together
we're all going down to one of the
beaches we're going to spend the
afternoon
you're on your [__] own for dinner i
was like fine go have a good time
knock it out you know i went i uh
i had some [__] to do around the house i
still had some boxes to go into
i threw some more [__] out you know it
was nice to have a little breather from
them
and at one point i went and i got it was
friday so i couldn't eat [__] meat so
i just went and got some chinese food a
little shrimp and garlic sauce
some steamed rice and like drop soup no
big [__] deal
i came home and i said you know what
nobody's home
i'm gonna go in the backyard and i'm
gonna [__] smoke a bone back there
the sun was out it was beautiful
there was a slight breeze my wife got
some back
yard furniture finally uh we got some
furniture
now we got a contractor to build mercy a
[__] clubhouse and
she's getting the dirt brought in to do
a little garden so we're just getting
our [__] together like i said
this is why i haven't even gotten a p.o
box because i'm still opening up boxes
and throwing [__] out
but uh i was in the yard it had to be
about 7 30.
just a beautiful [__] jersey night
the sun was still out
and i was looking at my yard and i'm
like how the [__]
did i end up back here like it's been
just a complete circle you know life is
a
circle but the funny thing was that
i was like i can't believe this is mine
that i saved up for 13 years
for a down payment it's been i've been
sober for 14 [__] years from that
miserable [__] drug
it's not their fault i snorted nobody
put a gun to my head
uh i've been saving money and finally we
scraped together put
um get our own house you know we
financed it it's not like i showed up
here like
buckaroo banzai and just wrote a check
we pay cat
nah we financed it like anybody else but
the point of this whole story is
that look so look at what happens when
you get involved
look at what happens when you get
involved okay
i got involved you know i get a lot of
emails
20 to 32 year olds listen man
as far as i'm concerned you're [__]
your life is [__] at that age i know
i thought my life was [__] at that age
you keep trying stuff
you move in with your family you move
back out you got a [__] roommate
life is a struggle but the most
important thing is that you keep [__]
pushing every day
you know and eventually you find
something that's your passion and
you [__] start from the bottom and
you keep pushing and you get the way you
want to go eventually
or you quit whatever the [__] your
decision is but you tried
that's the most important thing you know
mike gave me the guitar did i
i tried i'm still playing it am i
looking to be in a band and start
[__] motley crew 2
no i'm just looking to [__] play the
guitar you know
there doesn't have to be a thing but i
was just so happy that i got involved in
something that i found something i love
to bring me to the end of this [__]
journey that i loved it i i
i was very fortunate i i fell in love
with something you know
when i listened i retweeted that joe
rogan thing a couple weeks ago
and i listened to it like four times
before i retweeted it
and that's exactly how i felt at 25. i
felt that my guidance counselor had lied
to me
i felt that i had been lied to it you
know that i was not prepared to deal
with the world which i was not at 25
and most of yous aren't some of yous are
i say 60 percent of yours are
i wasn't and uh 40 aren't you
we just weren't prepared for the things
that were thrown at us
whether it was mentally because we were
doing drugs our weaknesses
whatever you know but i'm very happy
that i found a passion because if you
get
into something that you don't like and
you're making money and you keep don't
liking it
that's when you start getting fat your
wife starts spitting out kids
she's not the [__] model she was
she's 400 pounds every time you go home
she's dipping [__] chips an onion dip
you know your life goes to [__] you have
no control over and you [__] die
that's it i'm i was so self-conscious of
that when i was 25
i'm like man i got to find something
that i like that's the most important
thing i
ain't prison i went to prison at 25 i
didn't like that [__] i never
went back did i
know so what i'm trying to say to you is
if you're in that age group
you find something and you don't know
where it's going to lead you
you might start as an announcer as a
comic and end up
as a [__] tv host you never know
where this journey's going to go
but if you don't try you're never going
to get there that's
it's that simple this takes me to this
story in 1997
i had done a spot at the store i didn't
have a [__] car
i had to walk home i was probably
staying at
stan hopes or josh wolf's house or
[__] uh whatever who knows where i
was staying
but the comedy store is down on the west
side of sunset
and you have to walk past like the laugh
factory
so i said let me stop it it was a sunday
night i'll never forget this i said let
me stop in there
and uh
see what the [__] is going on so i
stepped into the lab factory it wasn't
my club the owner didn't like me at the
time you know
i was new in town he said i was more of
a club act and i accepted it i already
was getting spot this to store
i just peep my head in god knows why
maybe i was going to see ralphie who
knows
when i walk out i bumped into a kid uh
that i had known he was a funny [__]
guy
but he seemed a little down and i
talked to him a little bit and i asked
him what was the problem
and he said that they had canceled the
show he was on
he was on a superb [__] show i forget
the name of it doesn't really matter
what a superb [__] cast it's one of
those shows that should have made eight
years
like when you look at it in hindsight it
should have been on for eight years but
something had just slipped through the
cracks and this young man was a little
you know like you know bewildered he
thought his career was over
and i remember talking to him and going
you know bro you're just getting started
so what your show went down
look at all these people that their
shows went down [__] uh you know tom
rhodes and margaret cho
and greg geraldo they all kept pushing
just it's just a bump in the road and
you keep moving he's like [__] this
i'm moving back to new york and i he
moved back to new york and i
kept a loose tab on him i always knew he
was [__] funny as [__]
uh at the time that i think he was gonna
be a star where he had
already been on tv so he was well on his
way he had a lot more [__] going on than
i did
and over the years i didn't see him you
know i was doing my thing and then one
time i bumped into him on a plane
and we had a [__] interesting chat
and he even got me a [__] agent right
before the longest yard
which i [__] up and whatever but my
point is he went back to new york
he didn't cry he didn't whatever he just
picked up the pieces and started all
over again
and then i started seeing them on the
dave chappelle show
and he was killing it on there and then
you know
i just [__] kept hearing his name
and next thing you know i'm working with
him different nights at the store and
i'm watching this powerhouse
that i had seen 15 years earlier on a
bad night
thinking that his career was over and
now he became one of the best [__]
comics there is uh
in my world doug stanhope is the lady
bruce
of our comedy right now this this
situation we're in
but to me the best comedian working
today
i love joe rogan i love dave chappelle i
love john mulaney i love about bunch of
comics
but when i talk about pure comedy i
think the best comic working today is
bill burr
and i got him on the show today i hope
you enjoy this interview thank you for
watching
bill burr hey
what's going on how are you my brother
i'm great thank you for taking the time
it's great to see you
yeah dude you look happy as hell man
jersey is treating you right
it was time bill i'm an east coast guy
23 years uh i miss
my friends in austin you know i miss joe
and stuff but
it was time to [__] bring it on home
that's it oh yeah but i mean you're also
like you're still in show business you
got new york right up the street i don't
get
i get if you get 100 million dollars
going to texas but like
i don't know i don't know what those
other guys are doing
yeah i want to tease them so bad and
just be like dude you guys are literally
one argument from being out of show
business
everybody's one argument out of being
out of show business
yeah maybe there's some truth to that
you are uh you have been [__] killing
it lately just
killing me killing me for the last three
months you've been keeping me alive
oh thank you uh just little things
you're saying
my wife loves you on the disney show and
i'm like i gotta get you know
i actually miss you bill uh with all my
heart
i miss watching in the hallway alone and
watching the comics and it's just been
i'm trying to think the last time we
hung out we went we were at that guns
and roses show at uh the palladium right
oh my god and the chick passed out and i
kept oh i left before that
oh you left before the chick passed out
yeah they were a little late going on
and my [__] was i got you know
my wife was pregnant so i i was about to
have two kids so i was just like
i had a curfew i was 12 30 i am out
i am out anything later dr pink floyd uh
wish you were here once i heard that
part i saw the
i i saw i think i saw like
a half dozen songs but i had just seen
them
outside of paris it was just so
happening i was
i was gigging in europe and then me and
my wife
uh went to france or whatever and they
were they were coming through
and i got to see that i got to see that
tour
so uh the palladium thing was just like
a bonus
it was tremendous but it was it was
really cool to see them on the sunset
strip though you know where they sort of
you know
at least those original guys cut their
teeth back when that scene was there um
with duff slash and axel so yeah it was
cool
it was tremendous that was the best
concert i had been to
you know i started going back to
concerts about two years ago and that
concert
was [__] tremendous it blew me away
i didn't know they were that good but
that's 30 years bill bro
that's 30 years well that's what
happened
more than that 30 years 30 yeah it was
like 32
33 years since they made it so all the
years they played
just to be good enough to make it plus
all of those things
i was watching a thing last night about
uh was like a little documentary about
the
uh metallica guns and roses
tour that they did together which uh
was you know i would have thought that
they both could have done in arenas by
themselves
um i mean they still can't it's kind of
crazy they both can still do that and
they got on tour together
and they were just sort of talking about
how like no one thought that this tour
was gonna work
um i wanna say though that was the one
where
hadfield got burned right some pyro
technique went off at the wrong time
just got basically hit with the flame
thrower i mean that's just
my god it's like no one hit me probably
back like two weeks later
yeah that guy's a [__] savage
hatfield he don't give a [__] about
anything that was a good night though
at the palladium i had never been there
before
like i had never been there before at
all so
for me i just used to drive by and i
would see different people but that
night was just uh
tremendous my wife got a kick out of it
it was seeing you was great we were
laughing all right there was a girl next
to me
oh that's right that's right i remember
her there was couches up there
there was couches [__] up before guns
and roses even went on i think
even went on she was yelling and
screaming the whole hour because
guns went on like at 10 30. we got there
at 8 45.
guns were supposed to hit the stage at
nine i think or ten
they were an hour late and it was just i
went to see uh
aerosmith in 81 when they were just done
bill
right and i know you're a boston guy i
[__] love aerosmith
i [__] love them and they were done
joe perry had left
yeah uh some jimmy like joke jimmy
crispo
or something like that yeah something
like that was filling in
he had the joe perry project yes and i
watched i went to see him open up for
heart
at radio city so i felt bad like i loved
joe perry i said let me go see
[__] harold smith was that like a
like a [__]
like a little convention thing it was
like 300 people
tyler was so [__] hammered but there
was a guy in front of me that was on
heroin he kept nodding with a cigarette
and there were chicks with uh those
things that from the [__]
80s that what they would wear in the
summer a halter
tube a tube top and every time he'd fall
asleep with the cigarette i'd push him
into the girls
and he'd burn the girls back and the
girls would turn around and smack him
and he'd go right already all right and
then he finally would do it again i push
him into the girl
he burnt that same girl possibly nine
times
and then after one of those nods bill
burr he just fell to the floor
and everybody started kicking him during
the concert and that was the end of him
that was it and then somebody punched
even tyler in the face
oh this is one of these shows this is
how the show ended he went he had the
microphone
he put it out to the audience to sing
the scarves
somebody grabbed the scarves you don't
put the microphone out in jersey
you do that in ohio where there's nice
people you know what i'm saying and they
started going back and forth
finally he just threw the thing and he
dove into the [__] audience
and people were wailing on him
stephen not on the guy who grabbed the
mic was he giving a bad show or
something
it was a horrible show and what happened
was somebody threw a joint at him
he took the joint lit it and threw like
flicked it at somebody
and people were like what the [__] is
going on with you steven tyler
so you know how they pulled them out of
that they had to get him by his neck
from the stage and pull him up and as he
was going up
somebody just lay the last tour de
france on him
and they clocked him he got on the stage
and he ran into the back
and that was it done with mirrors that
was 81.
that was on core that night nothing
whitford had gone with the singer from
ted nugent
and they started their own band and joe
perry went and
started his own project which wasn't
that good either
to be honest with you and i love joe
perry but that's
that was my last [__] good concert
story you know now i'm around the corner
from jimmy florentine
you do know that right yeah i'm six
houses away that's the joey diaz project
we're gonna start with another queen on
rhythm guitar i just picked up the
guitar too i took
my third guitar lesson last week so i'm
making changes
yeah my i have to tell you something
jersey is good for you this is the
happiest
i i've ever seen the look you had that i
guess all the years i knew you you had
that i'm in la look
and it and i i think it really hit me
2016 was like i'm on a [__] ferris
wheel
but i can't get off it's not fun anymore
it wasn't fun the store was still fun i
love going to the store and
neil brennan doesn't want to follow me
so he would complain to adam every week
about i'm not following diaz then he
would come up to me bill burr
and say to me bill he would say and i
and i love neil brennan
i'm not putting them down how he would
come up to me and go
are you going to do a civilized normal
set tonight
i swear to god bill burr or are you
going to have any snow he told me he
goes
are you going to have any structure in
your set tonight civilized
so i would go up to him before but like
tuesdays he hated following me so he
would get there like
an hour before if i was a minute late
he would jump on he'd be so [__]
happy but when he'd see me
he'd i would see his head go down and
i'd go up to him and i go
neal when are you going to teach me how
to write i want to write like you don't
you have like a teaching
style a class that you could teach me he
never invited me down to his
room nothing because he hated following
me then he just stopped
that's that's something you you can't
run from that dude i had
like i had that everybody has that i
i had that with i had that with [__]
crystalia
for a while it was just like well bill
can follow crystalia
right which all right but it was just
like i
i don't want to do that work every night
why don't i get to come in and lean on
the mic still i gotta come out here guns
are blazing like it's [__] eight
o'clock nine o'clock saturday night on a
[__] tuesday um
and i felt myself starting to not like
him and then i immediately shut that
down because i'm older and wiser to be
like nah now now
you're getting upset because this guy's
making you work this is going to make
you better and and it's great for comedy
that there's a killer like this coming
up so
um that's one of the worst things you
can do
as as a young comic is to like i mean
you can have the anxiety and all that
type of thing but you have to face it
you have to face it oh and and then when
you get older
and there's the young bucks coming up um
you have to look at that as a positive
thing that's going to keep you sharp
it's going to keep you
you know uh you know on point and then
also the younger guys keep you
i mean not young but they keep you
contemporary
it's the reason why guys like vos and
don my herrera
can still do a show in front of 20
somethings
and me at this point i'm in my 50s it's
because you
if you stay around young comics you know
you still act your age but being around
them
keeps you up on what's going on
you just stay with like with like your
perspective like i went on in front of a
really young crowd the other night
there's this new room out here that's
sort of like the new dublins man it's
crazy like
you know celebrities are starting to
show up to it and [__] it's funny but it
was just started off as a little parking
lot
show but they just you know they're
paying comics and it's it's like
you know uh they're getting good comics
so people coming down words getting out
so i was up there last night
uh or two nights ago i went up there and
i was making fun of them but also
complimenting their generation
about like i understand what they're
going through
you know just i can't imagine in my 20s
when this is where i'm supposed to get
everything out before i get married
and then got to act like i never did any
bad [__] in front of my kids
like they they're like quarantined
during this how difficult
that [__] is and how when what how
little is left of the american dream
it's like i get it there's not a lot of
meat left
i just kind of went that thing while
being the old guy yelling at them for
leaving their [__] scooters all over
the place
so they kind of got like that sort of
angry old man in the yard thing while i
was compliment them but
it was one of those things but by
performing in front of them they were
keeping me
younger as far as like where my mindset
was but like
why they liked me was i wasn't trying to
act like i understood their music
or those stupid ass [__] scooters or
whatever the hell it is they're doing i
i was able to relate to them while still
being an old bastard
and um i got that great you know that
thing
beyond laughter will you you're
connected to him
absolutely yeah there's the funny joke
ha ha ha
and then there's this that that yes [__]
i thought it was just me that laugh is
my favorite laugh
other than uh you know these idiots who
who
you know feel like your whole act should
be tailored to
whatever their politics are those people
their look of disgust when i'm
on stage fills me up like christmas joey
brother what you're doing is just it is
hilarious and you know
comics are supposed to say what other
people feel
like and don't have the balls to say
that's
the blueprint that i was introduced to
when i started
last i think you're just supposed to go
up there and say what you think is funny
and it's in it's it's like nobody owns
the
uh the medium or the art whatever you
call it a stand-up comedy
it's it's however you want to do it it'd
be like what they're doing
or trying to do this really small group
of people because so much of the noise
is people at this point be like
kids or culture now they would just not
do that and let these idiots make their
little comments and not respond
it just sort of disappears but like um
i just i always felt like what they're
trying to do to comedians would be like
if you walked up to a musician and told
them what chords they were supposed to
play
in what sequence look you can write a
song from here
to here using these chords and these
notes but
if you use discord that means your
whatever
is kind of what they're doing now
imagine doing that to your musician and
you can't even sing
and you can't even play guitar that's
what they're trying to do
it's like you don't know what's funny
you don't know what what i can and can't
talk about what the [__] are you
here's a microphone you do five minutes
and let me see if i want you to be my
mentor
but i get to decide
let me tell you something nobody i don't
know
listen you're from boston no i'm not
from the suburbs
of boston kids in boston were [__]
lunatics
you're from a nice fight i was safe
suburbs you know you're from a nice
family
you're cultured i've seen you act you're
polite
how [__] brutal are those piano solos
for guys like you and me to sit like
when you see people in tuxedos i was
talking about on the podcast last week
people in tuxedos and they're sitting
there and they're watching some dude in
a violin
or like a piano solo and they're making
believe like they're into it you're not
into it
you cannot be into it you can be but
it's the scene that you shouldn't be
into but listening to
a musician playing any instrument at the
top of their game i could listen to that
all day long
i'm going to sit there with ruffles on
with a big fan of myself
right and going you know like that's
going to dress like the end yeah i'm
going to take out my lighter
yeah like you came out and said if i
listen to the guitar the piano solo i
die whatever the [__]
i was rolling when i saw that monday
morning i lived for that [__]
people don't know that the the grammy
thing
i was [__] wrong bill you have just
been
the thing about the thing i wasn't
saying that was a bad piece of music it
was
a hell of a [__] thing to have to go
like that's the comedy thing and like
we're all out here because all those
babies died
and we're gonna raise money tonight all
right your first comedian
it's just like dude what the [__] we
know why we're here
you're killing me so it was actually in
a roundabout way i was complimenting the
guy
who was p playing the piano because he
played it so well he created that mood
so perfectly that there was nothing i
could do other than address
the whole that he you know
not on purpose put me in i was reading
some of the tweets you know the respond
like oh my god
what is why is he there like what the
[__] is wrong with you it's a joke
no but that's that's a decent point
why am i there the fact that a comedian
yeah who's totally completely tone deaf
and can't even play
a [__] ukulele or a kazoo not saying
a ukulele is easy to play but if all you
[__] hipster douches get mad um yeah
how could i be eligible to win a grammy
i mean they have to come up with these
beautiful
pieces of music that make the world
dance and think about love and all that
[__] and i'm up there with like [__]
jokes
you know but what did i [__] expect
the producers had to hire you and go
we need a little levity in this [__]
thing let's get bill burr up there to
break the ice a little bit just
something
what do they expect it's gonna come out
of your mouth brother i had
i had a meltdown before i went in to go
do that thing i get freaked out by
certain things that i feel are too big
first of all i thought i was going to be
on tv i didn't know i was on the
pre-internet
[__] i mean standing in a warehouse
in burbank
you were on the undercard yeah you on
the undercard
of a [__] main card like you get on
fights they show after yeah if if the
main event went too quick it was like oh
yeah here's some [__] that happened six
hours ago yeah
i had no idea i went out bought a tom
ford suit blew all his [__] money
and uh so like but
i thought i was gonna be on the uh
the thing with the daily show guy and i
was like so i was freaking out being
like
okay so there's gonna be because there's
going to be like 2
000 people there spread out 2 000 people
in the [__] staples center
i'm going to feel like i'm in a giant
coffee house eating my balls
and the suit was supposed to be
delivered i had the wrong number
i'm trying to take my wife out to dinner
and i was just like oh enough i don't
want to [__] do this
i didn't ask to do this i didn't even
submit for this thing i didn't submit
for this
now i got to go down and wear this
[__] monkey suit so i was already
freaking out
and like as always as always i build it
up like it's gonna be [__] horrific
and everybody's gonna hate me and i'm
gonna have to go home and live with my
parents again
and then i went in there and i had a
[__] ball
dude let me tell you something free the
pre-grammy show
is where it's at through we
were i was making the camera crew laugh
the other hosts were hilarious
we were over there just having a [__]
great time man i
and i would do it any time they wanted
as long as it's the pre-grammy show i
don't want to be on the real one now
the pre one out in burbank that's the
party
that's where it's at you go to the
[__] uh
the real one then you gotta deal with
these people who are upset
that they didn't get enough nominations
or they didn't get nominated and they're
sitting there sulking
even though they already sold a zillion
albums
which was really disappointed you know i
really like the weekend
you know this is probably going to
damage the street cred that i like them
but just to see that guy be that into
that award i know there's other
you know [__] involved but like at some
point you got to be like look dude i'm
an adult am i going to get upset because
i'm not going to get a trophy
like what am i in [__] little league
you got to carry yourself with a little
bit of [__] arrogance like
i don't need your shiny thing to sit
here and validate
that my [__] jokes exist it's so crazy
what we feel like
my i for me one of the
best days of my life was when i'm
telling you this
honestly was when i tweeted the picture
of the guy i kidnapped with me at a show
i put you know 30 years ago i kidnapped
them now we're friends and i saw you
always tell these stories it makes me
feel like the cops are going to kick in
this channel i'm just like okay
a little less details i'm laughing
because i saw a tweet
from bill burr retweeted it you
retweeted that
you it's a picture of me with a guy and
i go i
i kidnapped this guy 30 years ago and
now he came to my show i really did
kidnap him and do time for
it and now he came back to my show when
i saw that you retweeted that
it it brought [__] i was so happy
that i put a smile on your face
on a monday morning but now let's take
the story
three years later i probably didn't take
it seriously i didn't think you really
kidnapped them kidnapped them and went
to jail
oh no i kidnapped them put them in the
trunk the whole [__] thing
uzi machine gun the whole miami vice set
up now
what kind of car did you have you must
have had like an old [__] lead sled
if you could get them in the car i
didn't have a car i drove a demo for a
car company i was a salesman my
accomplice had like a [__] malibu or
something
and we brought it right kidnapped car
great kid
the problem is he got caught in a
neighborhood driving with no headlights
on
and they pulled them over and they heard
hmm in the trunk
i wasn't in the car so they had to come
looking for me to cops but that's not
what this is about this is about that i
actually
kidnapped somebody that's one of the
nine predicates
like kidnapping is [__] serious
that's right i thought you got at least
20 years for that no
you're supposed to but it wasn't really
kidnapped it was second-degree burglary
but they charge you heavy because
kidnapping is basically moving somebody
from one room to another without
consent consent so if i say you built
get in the [__] bedroom with a gun
that's already kidnapping
so i didn't know that i didn't watch law
and order at that time see
now i'm up on the [__] laws now i
know that you can't now you'd say
bill sit in that chair in this room no i
would not i would that's kidnapping too
you know like people don't know that you
can't curse on an open line
from state to state if i call you up
from california to new york and i go
bill
[__] you you can actually press charges
on me you can't curse on an open line on
the phone a lot of people don't know
that but
regardless of that now that we're
halfway to this zoom thing what about
this
no we we could get thrown under the
[__] jail for this
but what i'm getting back to you at that
is what that
i kidnapped somebody and then three
years later you're on the phone with me
asking me because they wanted to cancel
me for laughing at you know
for saying i got my dicks 23 years ago
on the rogan podcast
and then you call me and say hey can you
call the dogs off or whatever was going
on
with our mutual friend they were
canceling me for something
i did 20. that's right i was the media
right with it yeah i came
in yeah i loved everybody involved in
that so uh yes you did
so but thanksgiving dinner settle down
we're all friends here
we're all friends look at this spread
let's call off the dogs i made special
stuffing
yeah but it's so weird that i
so you want to cancel me for telling a
story that joe rogan laughed about
but nobody cared about that poor bastard
in the trunk of the car
i don't understand that i don't i never
understood
you're preaching to the choir i never
understood this how
so me doing all those burglaries all
those years
and me robbing and doing coke and going
to jail
that doesn't bother you but me saying
that i got a blow job at the comedy
store
upstairs 23 years ago what you're
is the narrative the narrative what has
to happen is
what you do has to be outside the
narrative if it's outside the narrative
you can pretty much do whatever you want
to do
if what you do is within the narrative
did somebody just walk by a mirror am i
on my trip in here yeah no no
okay if what you do there it is again
i think your house is haunted if what
you do is within the narrative then you
have to be
on the the what they decided is the
right side of the double line of the
narrative if you go on the other side of
the street
then they will destroy your career so
the reality is is they don't give a [__]
about other people they give a [__]
about themselves
and because that that's where their uh
empathy lies
they are astoundingly
and ironically can be unbelievably
sexist reverse racist and everything
that they are allegedly fighting and
what's so funny is they don't
see it and i could bring up some
examples
that happened to me but i don't want to
drag other people into it but there was
[__] where
you know stuff that they were going
after happened to me
but because it happened to me and i
didn't fit the narrative nobody gave a
[__]
and would ignore that and then talk
about
three minutes earlier in my act that
didn't fit the narrative
and trash me and try to cancel me for
that so it's just like you guys are
doing the thing i always say it's a it's
a [__] buffet line
it's a buffet like they're just walking
down picking whatever
fits their thing you know i had a friend
of mine uh
they tried to cancel this person for an
analogy
for an analogy they didn't agree with
nothing you know racist homophobic or a
whole checklist not
it was an analogy that they did not
agree with
so it's it's like
you know i just saw a thing that there
was a guy a dad up in canada
his his daughter identifies
as as a boy all right i don't forget how
old or whatever
right so the daughter wants to
transition
the mother's cool with it the dad isn't
so
because he's publicly been speaking out
against
and also not referring to this person as
him
or whatever pronouns they want the they
were talking about putting him in jail
and it's like that's one of those things
where it's like
when i look at that thing it's like
everybody involved is going through some
sort of trauma and you have to have
empathy for the whole thing i have
empathy for i can't imagine being born
one sex you identify as the other what a
mind [__] that is
so you have to have empathy for that but
there's also another empathy where it's
just like
you know like i think there's degrees
you got to give people like
this like this is the person's dad
and the way you love a child and your
idea what they are i mean
give the guy a minute to [__] process
it where it's just like you know if i
just met that person
and they said hey yeah hi i'm
transitioning blah blah blah blah blah
i could yeah yeah okay cool whatever but
then you know then there's other levels
if i worked with you for [__]
five years and all of a sudden you joey
were becoming josephina there's going to
be a period of
what what the f and this all the
conversation we have and
how did i never see that but wherever
you are on that whole spectrum
of dealing with it is what you had you
should be allowed to go through
i mean the guy is not like um
you know he's just he's not there yet
and i just don't see how putting the guy
in prison
is going to like uh
solve like he's going to go to jail and
be like oh
now i'm open-minded now i got it
now i'm empathetic i get it
there's something about coming in here
and having to make a shank out of my
toothbrush and try not get raped in the
ass that i now
understand this it's like that guy
needs help he needs counseling so
i i i i'm confused i'm also not a lawyer
i don't live in canada i don't see
how grabbing this guy by the back of his
throat at the back of his neck and
throwing him into his cell
um you know it's it's
i feel like that is that is an
unbelievable thing for everybody
involved in to deal with and everybody
should be entitled
to their emotions and as long as they
are working towards
a common ground i feel like it should be
handled privately it's like none of my
[__] business
like i certainly wouldn't um
chastise nor am i right now chastising
anybody involved
or even canada for i guess putting this
guy in g if this is even a real story
it's like
i i'm just like saying that
that's a that's a that's a uh it's a
hell of a quagmire there
i got i got to ask you a question the
real reason why i wanted to talk to you
was
because of your recent i see a different
bill burr
i see a bill burr we've all grown from
this
we've all changed from this but i can
see
from during this time period this
pandemic okay you know
everything being shut down we've been
like the kidnapping the candidates
[__] all that [__] no the guy in the
mirror that's poor bruce lee
you know uh he ate an aspirin and died
what are you going to do but
i see your attitude i see your attitude
lately i don't know if you're doing this
if you're aware of it you are
unconscionable
you don't give a [__] if they cancer you
just like me but you're true you're
right i don't want to sell tickets
i know you still want to sell tickets
and you always will sell tickets
you're uncancelable because of the way
you're
holding yourself up as a man you don't
give a [__]
like we can't give a [__] i i did i give
a [__] too
but we're not supposed to his comics
no no i i listen i don't go out and try
i don't i'm not gonna be
like i don't set out to like [__]
hurt people i'm just trying to make you
laugh
that's it that's me too but my thing is
just like yeah it's just like
joey if you came up and criticized my
act i'm gonna listen to you
you're a comedian you know what i mean
it's just like
um and here's the thing too if these
people come up to me and i was in a bad
mood
and i let my emotions get the best of me
and i was really trying to be malicious
and hurt somebody then i am in the wrong
and i would 100 percent apologize
but you know
if you ask a comic what they meant by
it's like i was just joking around
i'm joking around and then then you
try to tell me that no you weren't
then you're basically saying that you
know what i'm thinking more than i do
i mean i get their paranoia because
there's a lot of you know there's people
that are like
oh no i didn't mean it that way this
passive aggressive thing in my heart of
hearts
i'm not [__] doing that i'm
definitely like
you know i like you know the deal if i'm
going up in front of a bunch of cops i'm
making fun of cops
that's just a comedy thing i did that
once i'm doing the grammys
you know we just played this beautiful
sad piece of music i'm gonna make fun i
mean that's what i'm gonna do
it's what i'm gonna do that's my [__]
job it's and you're laughing because it
is so ridiculous
what that guy played was a beautiful
piece of music that fit this mood
for me to walk on and do what i do after
what he did the joke is just laying
there waiting to be told and it's just a
[__] joke it's not like
i don't respect that guy and i don't
think he should have a grammy you know
it doesn't it's none of that it's just
me doing my job which is being a [__]
idiot
i wish people understood this for what
it was and they're not and they're
turning into something else and it just
it doesn't make sense to me either it
never matters i don't even like talking
about because it's it's so
few people it's so few people
it's so few people and i find those
types of people
ironically are
some of the most like
closed off walled off
um there is only one way there is my way
like they're like these little dictators
of of
thought and they can't even handle that
somebody they don't like
and they [__] [__] up and 80 of their
career still wants to go to some chuckle
hut and tell tickets
sell uh you know do his jokes and sell
some tickets
they can't handle that there's 200
people that want to go see him do it
they're trying to make those 200 people
not get to go and that's what for me it
gets like
now wait a minute like now you're kind
you're [__] with the whole thing
that's supposed to be freedom
i get that you don't want to go see him
i get or her
i get that a bunch of people don't so
don't go
but this person still has a right to be
like hey i'm gonna do my little
song and dance here it's so [__]
like it's like the fact that the clan
can still march
but if you get in the crosshairs of
these people you can't go tell your [__]
jokes in the middle of
[__] nowhere is like
you still can't but i mean they're
acting like like they're um
i don't know that that uh it's even in
my situation
you literally you're literally becoming
i mean isn't a lot of this like about
abuse of power and that type of stuff
it's just like i think you're kind of
abusing
your power at that point where
just this the whole the whole idea of it
the whole idea the whole thing i've
got to be honest with you is uh it's
more fascinating than frustrating
because i it's the thing those people
that try to cancel you i don't really i
don't
hate them either i find them confusing
i find them confusing i pray for them i
don't think that they're bad people i
just think that
there's something there's a void there i
i don't know what the [__] it is i
always feel like if i hung out with them
you give me 15 minutes and you'd like
me and you'd also see that your
perception of me
is probably 180 from what you thought
absolutely absolutely there's also so
much of doing stand-up at least the way
i do it
is trying to keep people at bay and
trying to keep you away from me
because of the way i
i grew up and the time that i grew up
people got in close they hurt you
so you you get this walled off thing and
some people
get that out by playing music some
people get that out
by uh uh acting some people get it out
writing there's a bunch of
working out all of those [__] i get it
out
by going on stage finding out what
bothers you
and then talking about it and getting
you right to the point where you think
i'm gonna say something [__] up and
then i don't but other people's lines
are different so they might think that i
cross or whatever but it's just like
i'm just [__] around i'm just [__]
around so
um yeah that's it there's nothing
there's really nothing happening here
nothing what's uh how's the family oh
they're awesome well my god
you got the sniffles right now so uh i
gotta wear like i'm
downstairs here but i gotta wear like a
mask in my house to make sure
you know nobody gets sick so right now
i'm just you know
i'm getting ready i got a little i'm
gonna do some uh my
one of my last zoom shows i think i'm
gonna do a zoom show
for new zealand and australia and uh so
i can hit the ground running so my axe
ready
you know i got the vaccine two days ago
both shots i got on sufficer okay
i got the first one so i feel fine i
didn't get sick or anything
my arm was a little bit sore but i had
an older brother so i grew up with a
sore shoulder
i was kind of used to that um
so but yeah it doesn't like this was i
got it on uh
friday it's six o'clock so it's a day
and a half later
you'll be fine on this one it's the
second one they say that's
knocks you down for 10 hours 12 hours
whatever you know you just
but i also feel like that that also will
come comes down to
how well you've been eating how many you
know where you you know
taking your vitamins and getting your
sleep i bet you're you're on the
shorter end of uh of what's gonna happen
by the way dude
i've been straight edged this whole
[__] month
which means
no drinking no drugs no not now i was a
big drug guy but like i
i quit drinking in 2018
and then gradually over the year and a
half
i just sort of replaced it with eating
gummies
and i just sort of realized i told this
story i took mushrooms for the first
time i
i heard and then that's that's what we
were getting to that yeah
and i um you know i had the the giggles
and you know i didn't take up
like crazy tripping but [__] definitely
looked like was it was breathing
you know the toilet looked like it was
breathing the tv looked like it was
getting bigger and bigger and it was
going to fall on me like [__] like that
which was kind of you know it was fun
did your wife know you were on them
uh yes and was she on them
uh listen listen i i decline to answer
that on the grounds i might incriminate
somebody
you got it um so i uh
after about it was about four hour trip
about two hours in i just had this
profound
sense of loneliness the exact opposite i
guess what you're supposed to feel
not being loved
and uh yeah i just that's why i felt
lonely and not loved so i'm laying in
bed i'm looking at my wife
and i'm thinking like jesus christ did i
marry the wrong person
you know which when you're married you
mean you think that every like five
and i don't think every five days now
it's more like once a month but back
when i was more volatile
every two three days [__] shooting
this [__]
screaming yelling like it was all me
right
but i was like all right wait a minute
let me think about my kids
because that's a no-brainer i know i
love my kids and i know my kids love me
and i thought about them and i still
felt it
same feeling so i was like all right so
this isn't that this
isn't this isn't them this is me what
the [__] is this
and i just laid there thinking about it
you know
and i was like oh [__] this is what i
felt like growing up
and this is what i've been running from
for the entire 30 years since i became
an adult
you know drinking and and [__] uh
uh getting in arguments with people and
just
trying to achieve [__] and just
just trying to just keep just keeping
the smoke behind me
and this was just sort of like you got
to turn around
and steer back into that and you have to
do it without an
altered mind because
that is not helping you and it's
affecting the people around you in a
negative way
so i you know i went back to therapy i
was already in therapy so now i sort of
know
you know like this like you know having
a glass of wine or having a gummy or
something like that
uh is you i i was never doing that
for the right reasons like
i had like this like i always just been
like [__]
uh like a car that's been idling a
little too high right
burning through the fuel and and and
i've always had like this
like that's where i was because that's
you had to be on your toes i was
basically
in the fight or flight mindset
for i don't know how many years like
when i was a kid i had like [__]
alopecia and that happened like right
through my adult year i would lose like
a clump of hair somewhere because i was
just
my body was like just so in like this
this mindset so now
um i'm sort of learning how to
uh
i read this i started to read this book
the verbally abusive
relationship and i thought the whole
time i was going to be reading it that
i'd be like oh that's so-and-so
and this is so-and-so and that's that
teacher i had but i was reading it going
like oh [__]
i do that page two hey i've been there
before
as much as but it made me feel good
though that i was seeing myself in the
book as
as painful as it is to see that you have
those elements
what i liked was i wasn't in my past
anymore
you know thinking about [__] [__]
that happened to me when i was
eight that like you know and i really
had like this
this thought at one point when i was
thinking about
all the [__] that happened to me with my
kid is that my perception of it
is not reality and the people that i
talk to
their perception of it is not reality
because it's somewhere in the middle
because when you're a kid
literally somebody walking up to your
bicycle
and taking a knife and stabbing the back
tire and letting the air out
that you that is your universe
that is like somebody just attacked you
everything that is you your freedom your
whole [__] thing
it's not till you get older it's like
it's a [__] bike man you know this
kid's a [__] you know whatever
go buy a new tire and a tube it's
literally this big
but when you're a kid it's from here to
the [__] moon
so the weight that you put on
adults when you're a kid is not fair to
the adults
and i think that's something that a lot
of people have a problem myself
included getting past like how could you
not know that if you did this that that
was going to affect me that way
how did i not know because i had [__]
10 kids and i was going to work every
day going jesus christ they're all going
to go to college someday
then i made some flippant remark or i
did some stupid [__] that i thought was
funny
but to you was [__] devastating so
they're wrong and i'm wrong it's
somewhere in the middle yeah it was a
[__] joke
and that gets back probably to the
cancer culture thing
that maybe i'm a little wrong and
they're a little wrong when the reality
is in the middle and i don't think that
the [__]
solution is that someone has to be
disintegrated
and then that somebody one person's
perception of it is
is what it is it isn't it's the same
thing with [__] politics
these [__] people watch cnn all day
or they watch fox news all day and that
becomes your [__] universe
and you literally lose the ability
i had a buddy of mine the other day the
other day he's one of these guys all the
time he's saying bill
that's not you know that trump isn't
racist they're [__]
you know this that that thing where that
guy went in and shot those
those asian women uh or people at that
at the at the uh
massage park at the spa yeah i don't
think it was racially motivated it's
just like
i was just saying all right all right
it's like do you understand how funny it
is that you're gonna tell a
a race of people that you're not what
they're feeling should be
[Music]
like i always love the white guys going
yeah trump isn't racist
it's just like so somehow all of those
black people are getting their own
experience
wrong day to day but you as a white
person who has never been them
and had to deal with a white guy like
that you that you
you have the inside scoop and i think
that uh
that all people do that including these
so-called
woke people like it's a really
um i think it's an astoundingly arrogant
mindset to be in to walk around
first of all to call yourself woke
it's like shouldn't somebody from uh an
impoverished group be telling you that
rather than you just putting those
stripes on your sleeve
i i i night myself woke are you woke
no nobody is no me neither nobody i'm
not walking i don't want to be moke
everybody if all of our if every if i
always
used to do this joke in my act if all of
your texts were made public tomorrow
could any of you go to work on monday
if every thought you ever you had during
the course of the day
there's no [__] way you're not
getting canceled
think about the times you've just driven
down the street going oh look at that
chick
look at that hot chick and it turned out
to be a dude or think of the times you
mean
oh look at the ass on her and then
you're like oh [__] i didn't know she
was that young
just that alone done think about the
things like racially how you've
perceived [__]
this all goes on in your [__] head
and these woke people
act like they don't do that act like
they are always just walking around
and they they every perception that they
have
is right i know that's not true because
i know what they think about me
and they're wrong and they're 100
percent thinking that they're in the
right it's it's it's
it's a very um and i'm saying this is a
ridiculously flawed human being
um that it is it is a a incredibly
immature and not enlightened way
to go through life to feel like
um you you have all the answers in the
way that you think
is correct yeah you should you know you
have your belief systems and you have
your gut
okay and you know and you have times
when you need to protect yourself
you know at nighttime walk into your
[__] car in a parking lot and it's
pitch black out you got to think the
worst of people you can't be walking up
all the leaves are brown that's how you
end up in trunk of a [__] malibu
right that's how it happened
yeah so um
but i also think that this sort of over
correction thing kind of had to happen
because it was so
it was so wrong the other way for so
[__] long
and i think eventually we're going to
come out of this because i think most
people
on the right and the left are in the
middle
going thinking like we need to dial this
back a little bit
you know like is with the canceling
and and then on the other side that
old school um
you know one of the one of the uh
red flags so to speak when you get on
the road
when you meet like a white dude it's
just like when they go uh there's
certain red flags that people say
if a white guy says listen i tell it
like it is
i know that there's an 80 chance he's
feeling me out to see if it's okay for
him to drop the n-word in about 10
minutes
that's been my experience on the road i
also know that when i meet women
who say guys can't handle me
i know that they are an unexamined
person who's a [__]
[__] who is now like in their ego
like yeah you know guys can't [__]
handle me it's like that's big in l.a a
lot of women say that that way yeah
i'm too much you know you got to be able
to handle me it's like
wow i just met you and you're already
trying to break down my self-esteem
that it's not that you're a jerk it's
that i can't handle you
and what they are doing is they are
putting that out there
and they're going to find a weak person
that they can manipulate
and they're going to abuse that person
for the entire time that they're in that
relationship
and you know this whole narrative out
there
that that's the guy doing it because
that whole
verbally abusive relationship was funny
was written a long time ago
it is written from the pers it's for
women
the whole thing is like it's it's saying
and whenever they talk about the victim
they always say she
so it was you know it's also because
of of how [__] ridiculously sexist i
imagine i didn't live back then the way
it was when it was written written like
in 1970 i think the first edition
something like that
and it was undoing all of these years of
the these
these you know toxic relationships
between men and women
where guys back then could use their
force their strength their bully and all
of that type of [__]
and and just did horrible things to
women so
you know you know the old me would have
got pissed and [__] not read the book
but i just said okay wait this was
written in the 70s
this book needed to be written it still
needs to be written
but like what happens is now there's
been this over correction i feel that
like
they don't understand that as a woman
you can do the same thing
you can do that to a guy very easily
very easily and um and if you combine
that with the fact
that guys aren't allowed to say that
they need affection
they need to he they need an atta boy
and that they need you that got you know
for guys we grew up and that's like weak
you know what i mean you're supposed to
be oh i don't give a [__] i don't need
anybody you know me joey
i don't give a [__] you know you got to
be in that mindset
um yeah those are the guys that are
usually
they get a little too many and they
start crying at the bar
those guys who don't give a [__] not all
the time but every once in a while dude
if you say dude what's going on with you
you have the goodwill hunting moment
it's not your fault
[Laughter]
[Music]
so there's a lot going on there's a lot
going on out there joey
so i'm happy that you're happy man i
missed you
physically mentally i miss watching you
on stage uh i'll tell you to your face i
think
that uh flying tiger whatever the [__]
your last special was
was one of the best things i ever saw in
my [__] life the levels
flying tiger hidden uh hidden hack
name of it doesn't matter i think it was
one of the best things i've ever seen
oh thank you i miss you uh and uh
congratulate you on all your success
well i already love coming back east so
the fact that i'm gonna get to see you
now because as much as you lived out
here we didn't
i mean i'd run into you at the store so
i'm not worried about uh
you know the the the tex-mex crew out
there
i know i'm gonna see all those guys it's
crazy how your dad was driving
and i had an efforts for family minute
like right now i'm living f is for
family
oh really yeah well frank is based
mainly on me
i'm more frank than anybody but it's
just so weird how
i i'm just a suburban dad now like i'm a
suburban dad that does
comedy that's it nope that's great dude
that's all i want to do right now
i know but that's a great that's a great
great thing
no combination you walk around dude if
you walk around feeling
filled filled up and feeling like you
have enough
um like dude this i have so much [__] i
want to get rid of
and i just don't mean stuff emotionally
from my past i have like you know
i got all these [__] free t-shirts
that i got at gigs and [__]
that means something to me you know i
got this t-shirt i'll keep this one
southpaw guitar
my favorite guitar store because i play
left-handed i try anyway
um and it's nothing but lefty guitars
and it's in uh houston texas one of my
favorite places to do stand up
love it too he used to love it oh yeah
all this stuff they know it's the first
place
i saw stan hope uh the first place i saw
you know mitch hedberg and all of those
guys i heard about the legend of them
then he had bill hicks and sam kinnis
and all that it's just it's just it's in
there there's something about houston
it's just [__] amazing so that's why
we didn't move to austin because i would
have cheated on houston
that's the real truth i don't want i
went to austin i just saw too many white
dreads and
food trucks and tie-dye shirts they wait
for [__] they wait online
i'm at houston texas and the traffic is
terrible i like i go
i go all the way i back with earl
campbell to houston monday night
football
earl running down [__] houston going
crazy
i remember being a kid
oh yeah
i like dallas and i like houston i don't
like austin or whatever
but like uh oh a red flag a red flag for
me
any city that uses the moniker keep it
weird
portland oregon austin
yellow springs ohio
i'm not saying i don't like those places
it's just like i know that i'm going to
run into a certain
intolerant white person on the other
spectrum
right same way i don't want to walk into
a clan meeting
i don't need i don't need uh like uh
vicious wokeness coming at me
with a bunch of white people i just i i
don't want to be around they're
nauseating to be around
and they're not weird you go there
there's a shell station
this is citibank wow it's so [__]
weird the oil companies and banks also
own you
there's nothing weird here tie-dye
shirts were in style
50 [__] years ago stop it
i love texas but i wanted to just uh
i'm more of a houston guy and i like
dallas too you know i grew up
a closet cowboy fan i couldn't say
nothing i [__] hated phil sims
but i loved [__] dorsett i loved
everybody down oh yeah so
i loved everybody roger stahlbach's back
tony door set robert newhouse [__]
joe dupree
golden richards drew i got it i got a
poster of hollywood henderson right
there on my wall right now i'll show it
to you
hollywood henderson have you ever read
his autobiography [__] yeah and i tried
to get him on the podcast
they're trying to sell a [__] story
of his life right now
and i told him why they don't make a
movie like people wouldn't even believe
it they wouldn't even believe
this is a thing too he was lawrence
taylor before lawrence before lawrence
taylor the reason why lawrence taylor i
always tell you this the reason why
lawrence taylor looks like he fell out
of the sky
was because the next the the guy between
a a dick dick butkus and lambert and all
of those
middle linebackers was
was uh hollywood henderson but he
messed it up on drugs so he was a blip
really quick i mean what that guy did
dude he returned to 1976 he returned a
[__] kickoff
they had a middle linebacker returning a
kickoff i mean this guy was otherworldly
and from what i heard lawrence taylor
that was his guy
that was his guy and you see him doing
that coming up into the play
fighting off the block of some 270
275 pound guys was the 300 pounders of
the 70s right
and making a play like that guy was like
was
one of the greatest athletes of the 70s
that played football
at the at the linebacker position he
just was unfortunately he just you know
they didn't know anything
dude when cocaine first came out doctors
said it's no more addictive than
caffeine
dude how about when he was he didn't
even know how to chop it up and he was
just doing straight raw cocaine he had a
[__] hole in his nose from one side
of the other
he'd pack it with cocaine before the
game and he would go out on the field
his whole face was numb
i didn't even know about this i know i
read the one book in the book
and then he would go in during the
locker uh in the locker room
and tom landry straight lace with the
fedora had no idea what was going on
he'd spend the entire
half time blowing his nose and then
repacking it
with cocaine as tom was out there doing
the [__] x's and o's about the second
half
dude it was it was it was wild
when they beat the denver broncos before
the game he crushed a can of
orange crush that's what they called
their defense or whatever
and i think that's the game he ran an
interception back and
he [__] won the super bowl i mean he
was just tremendous that guy
and then they fired him for what for
wait
they were losing and he put his finger
up that they were number one he had
drew pearson's towel company on
his in his pants right and they were
losing and he picked it up and he went
number one
and that's why he got fired i i i think
that was
it but he's telling at the comedy store
what's that he used to hang at the
comedy store yeah man
that that he lived in dallas he played
for dallas
but he kept the condo in la and he would
get a limousine with the pointer sisters
and they would smoke crack smoke uh this
one it was freebase rebates yeah
and they would go pick up richard at the
[__] uh comedy store
i think he's got two books i got i got
one here somewhere
well he he lived he lived a number of
books
i only read the one yeah i got like
there's two of them and i got one or
maybe two of them here
you know what's another great one you
ever read ken stabler's autobiography
the snake
no how about this one son of a vanna
luis tiant oh my god i gotta read that
i gotta send it to you this is [__]
this you know dawg
i grew up a [__] met fan but when the
boston red sox organization which is
known for being the cheapest
flew his parents in for game five
against the cincinnati reds fidel
let his parents come to fenway
you don't in 76 is 75 75
you didn't go to cuba without an
envelope to see fidel
and ask if his parents could come this
is a great [__] book i'll send it to
you
as a favor of thank you for doing the
podcast we used to do that man we used
to we used to
play great we used to play pitchers
poison right that's a game that died out
right you didn't have enough guys to
play baseball so the pitcher
pitching mom was first base and uh and
then anything off to one side of the
field wasn't out right
you just had to pull the ball so i
remember we used to do the louis teon
this might look backwards like i'm a
lefty but his [__] his [__] i can still
do it right
he'd go like this he come down he'd do
this with the thing
and then he would go all the way back
and then come around
all the way back um we used to do him
uh dude that's what back we used to
imitate foul
shots like you were doing impressions
when you were a kid because there was
there was no
you know the stuff that these kids have
nowadays man it's just [__] amazing
like i get why they don't leave the
house i get why they're
i get it too i get it too it's like you
can't judge them it's just like dude
the level of temptation i mean dude you
the flat screen tv
is a [__] movie screen
and some of them now with this this 4g
or whatever you feel like you can put
your hand into it
i compare it to you like low riders you
know when they put like 30 coats of
paint and it starts to look like water
and you feel like you could just put
your hand through the hood of the car
like tvs look like that
i'm gonna go outside and go play
pitchers poison
remember pickle you want to go play
pickle pickle pit pictures i began out a
play pickle that was you just you were
just someone would be running back and
forth you would just be practicing
how the [__] did you play pickle i can't
even remember how to play it like how
did the how did the ball get
into play i forget me too
a lot of years of reefing a lot of
smoking bill bro
we're almost out of here i know bill
thank you
i know you've been trying to wrap it up
for 10 minutes i'm i missed
it well my daughter's sick and my wife's
up there handling two kids right now i
was i knew i wanted to hey yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
no worries i love you bill all right
love you too brother i want to tell you
something man i
i looked up to you for a long time
you're one of the guys i looked up to
for structure
and you know when neil would bust my
balls i would go i got to watch for bill
burr
because i got to go i don't [__]
listen to him dude you go up and do it
the way you're supposed to do it do you
really think i listen to neil brown i
don't give a [__] about but he says i
know
i love you bill burke thank you very
much for taking the time
all right and for uh seeing you and i'll
see you when you come back i love neil
brennan too
i love neil too he's a director he can't
help it send them
that [__] my love love you buddy
thank you all right i'll talk to you
later see you
i hope you enjoyed that you bad
[__] that was a nice little
chat i had forgotten
all about that we even went to see guns
and roses like in december or something
before the [__] pandemic
it was great to see bill it's uh
you know i look up to him i like i said
during the interview with him
his new attitude is tremendous he
doesn't give a [__]
and that's the attitude that makes him
the best comic on the f
in the [__] planet he doesn't give a
[__] you know he goes out then he says
what the [__] he says
the piano thing almost all that [__] is
what a comic is really all about so if
you're learning
or if you're thinking of becoming a
comic yeah there's some great comics out
there to follow
but i really want you to watch what bill
burr's doing and
uh learn from it it's a state of mind
that you have to live through
you could tell people all you want that
they can't cancer you that's not it
it's a state of mind and how you hold
yourself and how you walk into a room
and bill's doing it all right he's uh
i'm definitely looking up to him as a
[__] mentor in comedy right now
but anyway thank you for watching i'm i
hope i'm you and you're enjoying this
new little [__] hybrid we're doing
from time to time
it's monday morning get out there sling
some dick
[__] april's on the way that's it
that's it we're getting vaccinated
the light is starting to come up the
shoe's going to drop
but the light at the end of the tunnel i
could see it a little bit you know what
i'm saying
and i know you guys could see the same
thank you very much for watching
have a [__] great week and thank you
for supporting
the joint [__] and now for a
word
for my [__] sponsors jack stay
black
all right you [__] suckers i want to
thank my brother bill bird for coming on
great guy great comic uh it was great
seeing him and uh
i hope you guys enjoyed him he's one of
the best in the business
but before we leave i got to talk to you
about some cbd
listen when it comes to cbd it's [__]
everywhere you go to a mall
there's some old lady with glasses
selling cbd you go to a [__] gas
station
the guy's got cbd can't speak english
but he's selling [__] cbd
do me a favor go to cbdline.com right
now
take a look read read read about all the
great cbd
cbn cbys and how they could affect you
they have a fine line of product
listen read the read their second lab
results you're gonna [__] die the cbd
lion is second to none
i've been working with them for two to
three years and i gotta tell you
something they've always impressed me
but during the surgery
they really [__] impressed me that's
when i saw the strength of cbd lion
so do yourself a favor right now go to
cbd line
just just just cbdline.com and just read
read up on your options before you go
buy it at some [__] gas station
what a [__] pawn shop or some [__]
like that you don't even know what the
[__] you're getting
it's like the union juice from the
[__] 90s remember everybody
had that [__] yang juice that they
liquor stores in 7-eleven you don't know
what the [__] you're drinking
when you're looking for cbd go to the
best cbdlion.com
press and code joey or church i'm going
to get you 20
off delivered to your house cbdlion.com
the best also the joint is also brought
to you by one of my favorite things
lately i've been having a great time
with it
i want a little money saturday night
draftkings 68 teams entered the
tournament
only the best have survived the upsets
have been
[__] crazy loyola illinois
oregon over iowa are you [__] kidding
me
draftking sportsbook is america's
top-rated sportsbook app
putting new customers in the center of
action you bet a dollar on any [__]
tournament game
and if that team wins you win a hundred
dollars is that [__] simple
okay how what my [__] [__] on fire
you're gonna turn one dollar into a
hundred dollars that's 100 to one
[__] odds you can't beat that
you pick any college basketball team
that's still in the hunt
at winning 100 one dollar and you're
gonna win a hundred [__] dollars
all it takes is a dollar bet and your
team to win their next game
there's no better way to put your
college basketball lives to the test
than with draftkings sportsbook app joey
you know what
college basketball ain't my thing okay
what about nba [__]
what about hockey what about golf and so
much more let me tell you something they
got daily boost
that will [__] make your head spin
they have things that make gambling fun
it's not calling that [__] jerk off
on the phone with the attitude and
what's the line on oklahoma and oh no no
they got games they're safe secure
reliable you when you withdraw your
money whatever the [__] you want at your
convenience
so do me a favor it's monday start the
week off right
you got a rabbit's foot in your [__]
pocket and you're not even rubbing the
[__]
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app right now
use promo code joy when you sign in to
turn
one dollar into a hundred [__]
dollars
a college of college basketball team of
your choosing pulls off to win
that's coach joey to turn one dollar
into a hundred dollars for a limited
time only at draftking sports books
and here's the fine print you knew it
was coming you always listen there's
always a by the way
you got to be 21 or older i don't know
what the [__] to tell you go climb a
tree [__] new jersey indiana
pennsylvania only new customers only
restrictions apply
you got to see draftkings.com sportsbook
for details but download the app right
now except
you got a gaming problem you gotta take
cares
i know you're gambling you're drinking
you're banging [__] transvestites you
gotta get your [__] life together
you're slipping [__]
but the gammon palm you gotta take care
of call one eight hundred gambler
or in indiana one eight hundred 1-809
with it okay
if you're straight it's time to get the
[__] party started
march is here it's almost [__] over
and i want you to
make a little [__] doe in the next
two or three [__] days
and april's coming next weekend that's
it we're down
download the draftking sportsbook app
today use promo code joey
and turn one dollar into a hundred
[__] dollars okay
i love you [__] have a great week
i want to thank bill burr
i want to thank draftkings sportsbook
app and i want to thank cbd lion
but most importantly i want to thank you
[__] for always having my back i
love you [__]
stay black stay healthy and have a great
week
you